but I remember one body was brought in
and the pathologist one of the
Pathologists was standing next to me and
I said who do you think that is and she
said without any shadow of a doubt
that's one of the terrorists there's no
legs the rib cage was basically no Flesh
on it and clearly the hold dog with the
bomb was either on his lap or by his
feet
I joined the flying Squad
in uh 2002 flying Squad started just
after the first world war and there was
a large uh Spate of uh armed robberies a
lot of the soldiers coming back from the
war couldn't get uh jobs a lot of them
were
traumatized um and uh in order to live
they basically did robberies and they
all KN knew how to fire a gun and there
were a lot of guns in circulation the
flying Squad was set up and the reason
it was called The Flying Squad because
of the first Timmy detectives to get
vehicles that had uh radio so they could
communicate with each other and they
basically dealt with all armed robberies
and their Forte is ambushing the
criminals as we call it going across the
pavement there was three things that the
flying Squad pride thems of is
speed uh aggression and
surprise what was you would say your
biggest case at flying
Squad
uh there was lots of them but the one
that Springs to mind which is quite
audacious uh it was a case that one of
my colleagues Jeff Jeff Davis who was a
DI on the team at the time a detective
inspector Jeff had been given some
intelligence that a gang of criminals
from East London that ran a boxing gym
uh had managed to uh get hold of a a van
or a lorry if you like that looked
identical to a cashing Transit ban and
they' painted it uh so it looked like
the real thing they'd even managed this
is the intelligence we had they even
managed that they were uh had
uniforms and they uh falsified documents
so if they went in uh to the office they
could um take out a large amount of
foreign currency that just come into the
into Gatwick airport but our
intelligence was very specific in as
much that they were going to drive
airide with all their false passes their
false
uniforms their uh camouflaged cash and
traget wagon draw this money from the
office cuz allegedly they had all the
paperwork and
um you know make off with it and it
wouldn't be till sometime afterwards
when the real cash and Transit people
come to collect it they discover that
the money had gone the senior officer at
Scotland Yard took a very very dim view
of this because it was bordering on
terrorism in a way because you know uh
innocent Travelers on the Airways could
have been put at risk in any event we
went down I think it was every
Thursday from about 4:00 in the
afternoon till midnight 1:00 in the
morning the whole team from our office
which was probably 25 to 30 you know
officers detectives men and women uh in
our um plane Clos cars we would drive
down to Gatwick Airport and we'd sit and
wait we heard a signal over the radio
there's a van coming in and it looks
like the one that's been monkeyed up I.E
camouflag look like the real thing
anyway we let them do what they were
going to do the money had come off a
flight from uh jalter in the event when
they drove out we uh put a hard stop in
which means we basically hijacked them
when they came out they offered no
violence they had no firearms no shots
were fired uh they were arrested brought
to London interviewed and you know it
didn't really matter what they said we
had all the evidence in the world and
they were subsequently convicted we
found out subsequently when we opened
the bags that uh there was about a
million pounds worth of Swedish croner
Norwegian croner Danish croner
euros and um and I mean talking a
million in each of those currencies so
it was would if they got away with it it
would have been a big
big uh big coup for them plus it would
have been a bad news story for the
police and Gatwick Airport cuz security
and Airport Air side had been
compromised plus as part of a wider
operation the I call the brains behind
it the criminal family they were all
convicted for conspiracy to Rob as well
I want to talk about the 7 s uh London
bombings can you talk to me about
working on terroristic attacks of that
scale right
um because of my experience in Mass
disaster my boss at the time who was
cresc a dick who subsequently became
commissioner came into my office and
said Jim what are you doing for the next
two weeks and I said well nothing I
haven't got any holidays book she said
good because there's been some terrorist
incidents in central London I turned on
the TV in my office and they were
showing live on sky and BBC the various
scenes where bombs had gone off one was
edra Road uh one was um Houston square
one was the bus in Bedford square and
the other one I think was uh allgate
East my first task was to go to uh the
London resilience Forum which was based
in
Milbank um and we set out how we were
going to set up a Margery Etc there was
no facilities in London at the time that
would been big enough for the number of
casualties we got we we started you know
looking at the scenes because it's a
murder scene the uh anti-terrorist
detectives had to go there and uh get
forensic evidence and I remained at the
Mory and I'll never forget when the
first body started coming the the trauma
was quite severe to the bodies you can
imagine in a a very small area in a
tunnel although the blast goes outwards
because of the concrete tunnel it's in
and in the train it implodes in after
that and the casualties were horrendous
but I remember one body was brought in
and the pathologist one of the
Pathologists was standing next to me and
I said who do you think that is and she
said without that any Shadow of Doubt
that's one of the terrorists I said how
can you say that she said there's no
legs
uh uh you know the rib cage was
basically no Flesh on it and clearly the
hold dog with the bomb was either on his
lap or by his feet and she said that
would be my conclusion we did no
invasive post-mortems we didn't need to
cuz we had metal detect detectors we had
uh Mir scans we had
x-ray uh we were able to identify
virtually every victim body that came in
I think after two weeks virtually
everyone that had been killed in the
incident had been identified I was going
to ask you what are the techniques of
identifying victims when it's such large
scale and the primary identifiers which
is preferable for victim ident ident
ification is
fingerprints although if you've got
fingerprints you're virtually alluding
to the fact the person has a criminal uh
background cuz why else although it's
more prevalent now you got Biometrics
and stuff like that there was more
fingerprints about but then it wasn't
quite the same and then uh there's
DNA and forensic Dentistry you can
identify someone uh by their lower
manable and their teeth but what took a
lot longer and was a bit more of a
headache was the property and body parts
because you imagine a Bomb Blast bits of
body go everywhere and that was
particularly true in the bus in bford
square uh there was bits of Flesh uh all
over the buildings and all that has to
be retrieved bagged up and identified
and it's ident ified using
DNA and the first time we ever did that
was at the Pennington rail crash and it
was groundbreaking stuff yeah and in
some cases I remember one particular
victim uh I think he was polish we had
to send the Polish police round to his
mother's address to get his toothbrush
so he could get DNA from the toothbrush
and then we married it up with his uh
postmortem DNA and it was the same you
can tell me about the Bulgarian is I
wanted to ask about hostage intervention
I think it was in 2005 we received a
phone call to Scotland Yard uh a woman
had dialed 999 and said her father had
been kidnapped he allegedly gone to
Bulgaria to Sophia to meet some men to
do a property deal he wanted to buy
property and Bulgaria at that time was
emerging from the Iron Curtain uh and a
close Association with uh Russia and
they were applying for EU and all that
stuff we told um the bulgarians what we
feared that a BRI National had been
kidnapped um and asked them to do some
intelligence gathering around it in the
interim uh the kidnappers had contacted
this woman and her family and demanded a
ransom to release him
to cut a long story short it was decided
that myself and a detective inspector
Ian horo who's a friend of mine we would
get on the next plane and go to Sophia
uh to assist the Bulgarian authorities
when we arrived it was
-20° there was about 5 foot of snow it
snowed massively in the preceding two
days uh and it was very difficult just
get from the airport to the hotel anyway
in the event I was asked directly the
question what would you do if this was
England and I said well if I knew where
they were and they knew the identity of
the people that had kidnapped him i' do
an
intervention um and you know but you
need to gather all the facts and all the
intelligence it turned out it became
more
uh how can I put it more of an emergency
because it turns out the victim was a
diabetic and he didn't have any
medication with him uh and clearly you
can't last forever if you're diabetic
and you haven't got any
medication so it became time critical
and the kidnappers were getting more and
more jittery because of the phone
traffic making all sorts of threats that
they're going to shoot him and all the
rest of it in the event I was told
late that evening by the
Bulgarian officer in charge that they
knew where the stronghold was they had
it
surrounded and did did I still want them
to do an armed intervention and I said
yes I do but you have to do a dynamic
risk assessment you got to make sure the
victim's life isn't at risk or it's not
going to put in any more danger than
he's in already obviously a right to
life is a basic human right even for
kidnappers and again members of the
public
fortunately very rural area no members
of the public were about and it was
getting quite late at night dark that
time of year anyway uh message came
across on my mobile phone from the
bulgarians saying uh two of the men have
just gotten a vehicle have left to go to
the local Village to buy some replies to
buy some supplies uh and I said well
they said to me do you want us to do an
armed invention I said well if you think
it's the right time I can't tell you to
do that it's your country but if I had
that
opportunity uh arrest the two don't let
them go back which they did no shots
fired nothing like that but
then um because of the conditions
weather conditions the snow and the full
moon uh the the guys that were doing
this by the way it's a specialized
Bulgarian police unit like the American
SWAT team they're trained in all this
stuff uh and they all had a profile of
Romo Greek wrestlers they were as wide
as they were as tall I mean they were
seriously scary looking people uh but
you know they trained for these
scenarios all the time very drave men I
have to say anyway they decided to
attempt an armed intervention they crept
up to the house uh the kidnapper uh saw
them because of the light conditions and
he had a a Markoff pistol which is a
semi-automatic russian-made pistol which
he fired at one of the police officers
who with his AK-47 came up to the aim
shot him through the head uh very
justified in my humble opinion we Rec
covered the hostage straight to hospital
he wasn't very well uh I visited him
Hospital the next day we interviewed him
got witness statement off him all the
rest of it that that was that really uh
and moving on from that they were all
arrested we subsequently had to go back
and give evidence in safia in the
Bulgarian courts and we actually trained
one of the uh the SWAT team the
Bulgarian SWAT team in hostage
negotiation which we arranged arranged
and then they had the full skill set
what would you say like three top most
important things in a hostage
negotiation
situation keep talking negotiation keep
uh Communication
open Proof of Life I.E you know you need
evidence that the person is still alive
uh there's a number of ways you can do
that one of them is get them send a
photograph with that day's newspaper for
example that's a very you know basic way
of doing it but there are other ways as
well um and basically try and play for
time try and wear down the kidnappers
you know agree to everything without
actually giving them anything if that
makes sense it's all about psych
psychologically wearing them out and
then starting to think well are we going
to get away with this uh is it worth it
you know and most things just to
reassure you most
kidnaps in this country
certainly uh are all because of drug
debts or uh about gang grab you know
land grabs where you've come into my
area and we've kidnapped you um where
it's very rare you have a kidnap in this
country of a member of the public for no
apparent reason do any of the cases that
you mention or didn't mention do any of
those cases haunt
you there's one particular case when I
was on the murder Squad uh there was a
six-year-old boy shot in the head and in
the t uh the thigh and he subsequently
died and we investigated his
murder and the reason he was killed it
was an act act of Revenge by his
mother's
ex-boyfriend uh he was a drug
dealer she kicked him out because he was
uh didn't like the little
boy
uh he came back to the house she'd
kicked him out he came back to the house
one night and
um he broke in he raped her he had a gun
went into the bedroom shot the little
boy in the head and the leg when he was
asleep and then to make matters worse he
made off
uh the W woman came out of her house
screaming completely naked neighbors
took her in called the police the little
boy was whisked off to Great Alman
Street hospital I think he lived for 48
hours but subsequently died of his
wounds um as you can imagine the mother
was
distort so we had to debrief her but
obviously in a very sensitive way that
same evening two uniform officers from
ful police station we' circulated this
particular individual and his car number
uh to all officers to look for him the
next morning in King Street Hammersmith
the car was spotted again and uniform
officers again gave Chase all unarmed
they rammed the
car uh
and they arrested him after a really
violent struggle he was asped that's
like you know police metal bar trun and
type thing uh he was CS Gast and he was
still
fighting
um none of the officers were armed but
they managed to subdue him and they
found the gun and it was fully loaded a
revolver and one of the officers said
I'm sure he he put the gun out the
window and was going to fire at me and
we proved forensically that the gun had
jammed so probably would have or could
have been responsible for the murder of
at least three police officers it's the
first time in my service and I've
investigated many murders first time
I've ever known anybody plead guilty to
murder he pleaded guilty so we prevented
a
trial and why why do you think that one
has this the age of the kid six yeah
six-year-old boys shouldn't be shot and
killed how do you deal with emotional
and kind of mental Lord of this work uh
well it's a job um and some things
affect you more than other I've been
quite uh I'm quite a resilient
individual um generally what works for
me and this work
particularly uh on this particular
murder Perry's murder
and uh particularly the horrendous
uh State the bodies on the Paddington
rail cross and the seven seven seven
bombings is I go to the pub with my
colleagues and we talk about it we don't
bottle it up we talk about it and you
know you you get it all out there
basically there has been a lot of
criticism of met police in in the recent
years what is your view on all of those
uh I think the RO recent um criticism
around Sarah avard
is is you know well well it's well
documented by every aspect of the media
uh Wayne cousins is a wrongin pure and
simple he should never have been in the
Police Service uh he wasn't what I call
a proper policeman he was a guard
holding a gun outside the American
Embassy I just question who is vetting
these people and uh there are Clues and
their behavior colleagues have said oh
he was called the rapist well didn't you
go and speak to a senior officer and say
you know we're not happy about this guy
there's something not right about him uh
but you can't wash your hands of it it
we all have ownership for corrupt
policemen for Dangerous policemen we you
know you got to do something from within
but I have to say part of this is all to
do and it's not just the police it's the
Judiciary the prison service the
national health is the age of austerity
foed Upon Us by David Cameron and George
Osborn and the worst Home Secretary in
my view in my lifetime Theresa May
they've just cut cut cut I remember back
in the day there was police stations all
over London we were taught in training
school that police station is a place of
safety well there aren't any anymore if
you're a late at night you haven't got a
taxi to get home whatever they used to
turn up at police
stations and a lot of the time a police
officer would drive them home or they
call a taxi to the police station or
they could sit there till a member of
their family came to collect them that's
all gone it's a varable career and it's
it's it's a lot of things do you feel
like you've you've changed the society I
don't think I've changed it I
mean probably in many ways I I was
picking up the bits that Society doesn't
want to deal with
um but the job satisfaction you get is
that you bring somebody that shouldn't
be walking around out there to Justice
hopefully they get locked up for a
number of years so they can't do it to
anybody else and more importantly to
give closure to the loved ones of the
[Music]
victims Angelica clo had been battered
over the head with a tap leg she'd been
gagged and her wrist were bound cable
ties she'd been stabbed